in all the panelists and and ronald's uh
video
so um so as he's doing that let me
let me introduce the panel uh so
uh we have um
we we have uh uh on the panel
uh andrew chiles who who is um
from the university of maryland uh
andrew also
co-directs the joint center uh
with um witnessed
fix uh andrew has done extensive work on
quantum algorithms on quantum walk
algorithms
uh you know exponential speed up by
quantum work on
on quantum simulation and um
uh and he was actually you know he
he got his phd from mit uh actually with
uh
with eddie fary as as advisor so
um that brings me to the next person on
the panel who is eddie fary
uh besides being andrew's advisor he
uh you know he has a lot of
uh you know he's he was uh uh
he pioneered these uh you know walk
continuous walk based algorithms um
uh quantum adiabatic optimization as
well as qaoa
um you know he's he's currently a
principal scientist
at google for uh working on quantum
computing but uh he is to be
uh on the faculty at mit and the
director of the
of the center for theoretical physics
there
and um we also have ashley montanaro uh
from the university of bristol uh in the
school of mathematics uh
he's um you know obviously worked on uh
extensively on quantum algorithms for
over 15 years and he's
uh in including the finite element
methods that uh that ronald mentioned
but he's also the co-founder of
of facecraft which is a quantum software
starter
um incidentally that's a that's a great
name for uh for a quantum
company so um uh so i
let's let's move on to the to the panel
it would be
uh you know we'll start with a bit short
uh maybe two to three minute uh
comments by each of the panelists both
on
any aspect of ronald's talk you'd like
to talk about but
but that's also you know broadened
broadened the discussion also to to
heuristic
optimization you know including qaoa
and variational methods and so on um
and then you know uh it would be it
would be good to hear about
anything you have to say about those
methods including you know evidence for
speed ups or
for reasons that you might you know uh
work on that but also um
i think it would be it would be
interesting also to hear about um
you know your opinions about uh um
you know a what are the most promising
quantum algorithms
in at whichever level you want to think
about them in their
in their in the near term and the medium
term or in the long term you know what
what you would think of as the most
promising approaches
as well as um you know if you were
advising
a young researcher to work on quantum
algorithms what
directions would you would you suggest
to them so
you know anything that you would like
you know in other words i'd like you to
talk about anything you'd like to uh
about this subject so uh
with uh
anyone want to start or shall i you know
should we go alphabetically
maybe i can just start if it's okay
because i actually need to head out and
be 15 minutes which i apologize for but
yeah oh yeah um
yeah so um yeah if i could just uh uh
just
take a couple of minutes i mean maybe i
would start just with a minor quibble
with something that ronald said you know
in the talk which is that
um you know he sort of identified
simulation as maybe
one of the three main applications of
quantum computers you know along with
crypto and and simulation and um uh i
think that
maybe there's a difference you know with
these these three things i guess for
sort of crypt analysis and for
simulation we have i think
you know really compelling evidence that
there are exponential speed ups whereas
for optimization at least you know
from what we heard in the talk uh you
know i think there's lots of really
interesting
uh polynomial speed ups but you know i
guess ronald also talked a little bit
about why maybe we
um you know may have to wait a long time
before we before those turn into
something
practical so um i think you know i guess
the evidence for
like exponential speed ups uh for for
optimization
is um you know much less clear i think
and um
so i i you know i agree that i would i
would sort of highlight this as a
potential
application of quantum computers and a
very interesting one but maybe not quite
at the same
sort of with the same status as sort of
crypto and um uh
simulation i mean i completely agree
with that it's clearly the weakest of
the three things that i mentioned
yeah yeah okay okay good um
good to hear i mean i i would also say
that you know i feel like
um you know there's lots of really sort
of from a theoretical perspective lots
of really interesting things to say
about uh polynomial speed ups i mean we
heard many such things in
in this you know really beautiful talk
and i think this is a really interesting
area
i mean one sort of question that ronald
mentioned that i think is you know that
i've been particularly interested in is
this question of
you know the the sort of speed up we can
hope to get for general convex
optimization
from from quantum computers i think
there's some really nice you know still
open questions there where there's
you know even some potential maybe for
um super quadratic but still only
polynomial speed up so i think that
that's
you know potentially interesting even if
not you know likely to be super
practical in the
in the very near term um i think it
would be great to you know
sort of think about the possibility of
actually getting sort of provable
exponential advantage for some kind of
optimization problems i mean i don't
think that that's
somehow completely ruled out we just
don't know exactly where to go
um you know there's there was this nice
recent result about sort of exponential
speed ups for
graph problems with cut queries that you
know happened maybe a year ago
um so i mean i think you know there's
still the possibility for identifying
new
sort of interesting exponential kind of
speed ups um and
i would also really like to hear from
eddie sort of like um
uh sort of you know where things stand
with respect to sort of you know
adiabatic optimization qaoa i mean i i
do think that there's a lot of
you know potential there i think the
situation is to me very unclear but
it seems like that's something a lot of
people want to hear about so um yeah i
would like to hear more about what he
has to say about that
okay so i guess it's my turn yeah so
one thing is is that um ronald you
characterized the qaoa
as a variational algorithm in this
euristic
and i would like to say something about
that
well first of all the qaoa at the lowest
depth
you can find the optimal parameters in
advance
and by classical methods so it's not
variational
and second of all it at the shallowest
depths
you have worst case performance
guarantees
and i think that you know you should not
overlook the fact that
we can guarantee for example our max
cut on three regular graphs an
approximation ratio of 0.69 something
now
you're going to say that that's not as
good as the best classical and i
would have to agree with that but i
think you should not downplay the fact
that
in this space we have techniques which
we never had before
to get worst case performance guarantees
on optimization
and and for the qaoa as the depth
increases it can only improve and you
can find the parameters in advance
so i would not call that a variational
heuristic i would call it a
algorithm with specified parameters with
guaranteed worst case performance
guarantees and i keep saying that
because i think that makes it um
people should use these things and and
well first let me say one other thing
and then i'll say what i think people
should do
another thing we did recently is we
showed how to analyze the qaoa
at any depth in the up for the sheraton
kirkpatrick model
in the infinite size limit okay so we
took
we took random instances of the sk model
which is an all to all model you have
i'll just define it for those who don't
know
it's you're on a complete graph with
plus or minus one couplings
on every edge and we were able to show
is that for typical instances
that um we could analyze the performance
of the qaoa this is a fixed p
after we took n to infinity so it's as
shallow as you could imagine
because we've already taken it to the
infinitely big and
we were able to get an iteration that
allows us to
measure the performance of the algorithm
and you know we passed this sd
p value uh and again
and and we get and we we can find the
parameters
and they concentrate which means you
have the same parameters for every
instance
so i would not call that a variational
algorithm because if you find the
parameters for one instance
they work for all instances and
um i could we proved all these
concentration results
so i think that there um
again it's not variational and it has
worst case performance guarantees now i
know
that we haven't been able to beat
monteneri's
algorithm for this problem where they're
in the last two years there was a huge
breakthrough in this field
when andrea montanari was able to get um
an algorithm which comes within one
minus epsilon the best value
in time that goes like one over epsilon
squared now we haven't done that yet
okay but that's only two years old
and so i you know i would i think
there's huge room for
people to play here like you know why
can't people
try to take the techniques we used for
the sk model where we do
typical instances provable results
and analyze other problems random
instances of anything
graphs max cut on you know
any kind of graph you like or take the
approximation try to go to higher depth
and i am not impressed with the fact
that you know there are
that hastings wrote a paper showing that
at p equals one
he had an algorithm that beat the qaoa i
mean so what
i really couldn't understand that it was
beyond me why people thought that was
interesting and i'm just being blunt
about it
and especially since at p equals one the
qaoa
also has supremacy so it's a it's a
quantum algorithm
if it did i mean it has supremacy you
can prove that
you can't sample from the output
distribution according to the standards
of
uh you know whatever it's a very you
know it's very rigorous it's like um
one of those things i p something
circuits it's the same thing
but you know so it's obviously a quantum
algorithm otherwise it wouldn't have
supremacy
and so and okay i'm going to keep going
since you pushed me
you know so you know the other thing we
did last year
is we showed that the qaoa will fail
if you don't see the whole graph in
something like
max maximum independence said on a renny
graph
and we rigorously prove this is me david
gomarnik
and sam gottman we use some of the same
techniques that gomarnik and sudan used
to show limitations of classical
algorithms local algorithms
and we use the locality of the qaoa
to put on maximum independence set
on on a deregular graphs so that they
don't they're not halt all connected
to show limitations of the qaoa but
those limitations are only
for p less than a constant times log n
and once your p is bigger than log n you
see the whole graph if it's a random
graph
and then there's no indication no
indication
that the algorithm will fail none
and so what can i say i mean and also if
you put the numbers in for the
what we found on maximum independence
set if you're in a million qubits
and we and and your three regular which
is the least
spreading possible you only could show a
limitation
for p less than seven and bravi's result
is
weaker he shows you know he at two
million qubits he can only show the qa
where he fails at like p less than two
so i don't know it seems to me that it
seems like a very
fertile area for exploration
um you know can we analyze the qaoa at
higher depth can we get provable results
can we look at typical instances can we
prove limitations i think it's
i think it's anyway that's my pitch okay
thanks
thanks eddie thanks for that so uh
ashley maybe do you want to yeah sure
okay i'll go next um so first uh i
should apologize that wasn't able to be
here for most of ronald's talk so
hopefully what i say is not totally
disconnected from from the discussion
oh yeah one thing forgot to say you gave
a great talk ronald i'm so sorry i
actually interrupted
thanks i'm sorry five minutes i thought
we're indeed
indeed great so um and um
yeah so i think i'll maybe just focus on
on part of your question you miss which
is the the question of what seemed to be
interesting directions
for the future and i guess ronald
mentioned
and we've discussed this sort of
interesting dichotomy that we've got at
the moment
in in the world of optimization problems
where we have these
beautiful um quantum algorithms where we
have rigorous performance bounds but
often
the it's quantum speed up is perhaps not
as big as we would like it's kind of
quadratic or something
whereas we've got these um more
heuristic kind of algorithms
uh which may have an exponential speed
up and maybe you're suitable
in the near term but we can't prove it
and i think
for me there are really interesting
directions in both of these
sort of lines and when we think about
the
the rigorous um algorithms i think what
one thing that
was maybe clear from from ronald's talk
is how many really interesting new ideas
we get when we think about this
uh this line of work so i mean for
example the quantum algorithm for
escaping from saddle points which
mentioned i think um this this is a sort
of really nice
new technique involving um looking at a
sort of quantum
simulation of the schrodinger equation
to somehow solve optimization problems
more efficiently than
we expect to be able to do classically
which i think many people like me would
not have expected would be possible so
i think this um this can really give us
new ideas which may end up being useful
for larger speed ups
and i also think that these rigorous
algorithms are really important for
fundamental reasons i mean if we think
that quantum computing
is a sort of deeper thing in classical
computing because quantum mechanics is a
deeper theory in classical mechanics
then pinning down the precise complexity
of some fundamental computational
problems
should be even more important than the
classical case and if we're willing to
spend
decades understanding the complexity of
matrix multiplication classically we
should also be willing to pin down the
complexity of some of these problems
constantly
but i guess the the flip side of that is
that these problems should really be
fundamental ones because
um these algorithms you know that
achieve a quantum speed up of
a power of 0.01 are probably not going
to be practically relevant so we should
really care about the problem for some
sort of deep reason
and on the the sort of uh the the
heuristic side i guess
i would say that one class of algorithms
that
was mentioned but hasn't been discussed
i guess so so much today
is these algorithms for solving problems
to do with quantum mechanics so
for example um simulating quantum
physics systems quantum chemistry
systems this this kind of thing
the eqe algorithm and i think like it's
clear that
i guess the community thinks that this
is an exciting direction if you look at
the deluge of papers on the archive
where people are doing
uh first the experiments but also coming
up with new algorithms and new ideas
in this direction and i think there are
several reasons for that i mean one of
them is that
there are exciting practical
applications um
and uh another i guess is the fact that
there are some nice contributions you
can make it's a sort of very wide open
area
and um as you know finding now having a
quantum
startup that there are many sort of
interesting problems that are of this
more sort of applied flavor to do with
um simulating quantum systems where you
can apply
sort of algorithmic thinking and get
some sort of quite interesting speed ups
and um can can make some perhaps really
practical difference to the performance
of these algorithms
um i guess i guess the last thing maybe
i'd like to mention is about
these heuristic algorithms for
optimization that eddie discussed a lot
um i mean i think i i guess i would
agree with with eddie then said that
although
perhaps some of these algorithms do not
have yet as yet dramatic performance
improvements over
the best classical algorithms we have um
somehow
we don't really know like what the
potential is of this this direction yet
i would say and i think this is
particularly important when
we think that in a few years time we may
have quantum computers that have
thousands of qubits um but perhaps not
great fidelities yet
and so these algorithms that might be
very low depth and sort of heuristic and
sample from some interesting solution
space could become very important
and i think um yeah i guess
another interesting question this this
area is
can these algorithms find solutions
which are not necessarily better in
terms of having a lower energy
or sort of satisfying a large number of
constraints but they're somehow
different
in the sense that the set that this
quantum algorithm sampling from
is somehow a set which would be very
challenging for the classical algorithm
to sample from and we think as eddie
mentioned that this should be the case
that we could do this sometimes because
of these quantum supremacy type
arguments
and could it be the case that the
solutions we get have some interesting
features which we don't see classically
and i think this
is a really interesting question to
explore i think that's everything
thanks ashley yeah so uh maybe we can
that's really how interesting so can we
turn to ronald
uh do you would you like to your
reactions
to i guess i mostly want to respond to
eddie
um so first let me say i think qaoa is a
very interesting idea i basically sort
of
put it aside at the start of my talk not
because i think it's stupid thing but
because it's different from the things
that i wanted to talk about
right and my calling into heuristic i
call it the heuristic in the following
sense
uh the cases where we can analyze it
it's no better than classical algorithms
the cases where we have hope for a speed
up we can't prove anything it's a
heuristic in that sense right
something is a heuristic at a certain
point in time like at some point
later point maybe you can actually
analyze it and it converts from a
heuristic to a to actual analytical
result
i don't i can't follow what you're
saying i just can't parse it i mean
it's i can analyze it it just doesn't do
as well as the classical but still
analyzable
i mean this is exactly exactly what i
mean right
well i thought heuristic is something
you can't analyze a university is
a process but you don't have the power
to analyze that's what i thought
maybe i'm mistaken i mean heuristic
isn't an algorithm that doesn't do as
well as a classical algorithm a
heuristic is an algorithm you can't
analyze right
that's what i thought you meant no no
what i meant is i
make a distinction between the cases
where we can analyze qaoa
and other variational algorithms in
those cases those things are not
heuristics
but unfortunately they also don't
perform better than classical algorithms
on the other hand there are the regimes
where we cannot prove anything
where we do have some hope for good
performance and there i would call them
a heuristic
okay that's fine
and it's certainly worthwhile sort of
trying out these things right one of the
the great features of qaoa is is you
don't need to worry about qram
yeah right if you really hate qrm that
sort of sinks 80 percent of my talk and
it doesn't sink
qaoa
but but on the other hand let me just i
think qaoa is getting a surprising
amount of attention given how little
indication we have that it actually
outperforms classical algorithms
well i would say it's more there's a
simple reason for that and it's very low
depth i mean you get proofable
performance guarantees at the lowest
depth
and like actually said we're going to
have quantum computers at low depth and
what else you're going to run on them
you know and so it's the obvious thing
to run on a low depth
machine it's a very low depth algorithm
i think i agree with that but low depth
is not set in stone right hopefully in a
few years time this low depth will get
bigger and bigger depth and at some
point it will transition to
uh to hopefully to the kinds of
algorithms that i discussed
sure but i mean if you have a quantum
computer now i mean
you know you've got to run something and
actually yeah yeah so
so coming coming back to a question that
i asked earlier you know so
if you were to if you were to look out
further into the horizon medium or even
very long term
what what would the algorithm be that
you know what what algorithms would you
actually be
saying are the most most promising or
the most interesting
you know i mean i think quantum
simulation is probably the most the most
interesting thing more in the sort of
like
medium term or i mean i don't know
what's what counts as short term and
what counts as medium term but i think
you know i think we it's it's i think
it's also kind of unclear just how
useful quantum simulators will be in a
you know
nisk kind of regime in the sort of you
know where we are now or what we can
expect to have
in five years but i think you know i
think if you look at the sort of um
overheads of kind of you know even sort
of quantum
simulation algorithms as compared with
like factoring
you know probably you can you can expect
to solve um
interesting instances of quantum
simulation problems sooner than you
then you could factor uh you know
thousand bit numbers and also by the way
why do you want to factor thousand bit
numbers because you know it's
pretty pretty limited utility so uh and
i think that that's going to be useful
like
far far beyond the you know i guess you
know ronald discussed this
you know uh when you have quadra
quadratic speedups and the constant
factor is 10 to the 10 you know it's
going to be
a really long time before a quadratic
speed up is going to be a useful thing
so
and so if you if you were to pick a pick
a winning
quantum algorithm for simulation in that
in that regime
you know in whatever regime into the
future what
what would your what would your uh
i mean i think probably just you know i
think it's going to be as simple as
possible to be the thing that we're
going to do in the nearest term and so i
think
you know maybe sort of like
computational you know condensed matter
physics is maybe a good candidate
because you can look at very simple spin
models where you can
you can see for example these kind of
like you know thermalization transitions
or something like that you can ask
questions about them that
you know it's maybe not not obvious how
to analyze these systems they're they're
you know probably beyond the reach of
classical simulation and there's
probably interesting things you can
you can say about them now this is maybe
not as exciting as you know
designing a drug that's going to be you
know
save lots of lives but i mean you know
doing doing some kind of computational
uh you know
uh theoretical physics would be i think
you know
a very interesting thing that would be
beyond sort of just demonstrating you
know
the sort of power and principle of
quantum computers
i guess if maybe if i can uh follow up
on that and i guess
for me i i'd completely agree with
andrew about applications in quantum
simulation of various kinds but
simulation doesn't necessarily mean just
time dynamics maybe it means
for me something like vqe like
understanding sort of
low energy states of a quantum system or
something and i guess i would say in
this sort of medium-term
sort of era um something slightly
between these two points that andrew
mentioned i think seems very exciting to
me these two points of
um condensed matter physics sort of do
it basically doing a physics experiment
but on a complete computer
and then designing a new drug you've got
um in the whole region the middle you've
got things like materials science maybe
understanding some
physical system which still sort of
seems to sit more naturally within
quantum physics rather than chemistry
but somehow it's maybe
uh and is maybe more well suited for
study on a quantum computer so maybe
designing new batteries new solar cells
things like this
um i think for me these are all things
that are interesting in this medium-term
regime
and of course to some extent you should
also be able to combine quantum
chemistry simulations with optimization
where you have some sort of toolbox that
simulates the behavior of a certain
molecule and then you
try to optimize over different possible
molecules to find one that
that behaves uh the best
but the question is if you want to put
your whole optimization algorithm in the
quantum computer though right somehow
because
then maybe actually squeezing this this
big molecule in becomes more challenging
but
yeah that's quite right yeah
um so and andrew unfortunately had to
leave
he he had told me in advance he had to
leave
closer to 12 30 so he he stayed as long
as he could
um yeah i i i guess um i didn't get a
chance to ask him but um
you know what what i had meant to ask
him you know was was not just
what the application would be but which
particular algorithm would he
think you know because there's several
algorithms for for simulation
and so my my question was more
you know not just which application
would you
would you think is the most interesting
one but which particular algorithms
would you
think are going to be the most relevant
or the most interesting ones
say as you look out into the future
well maybe i'll just just continue what
i was just saying in the sense that i i
think
for me um i i think vqe really will be
quite important and
i think one reason for this is that i
think
um rather than just thinking about this
in terms of
like an optimization task let's say
finding like the ground state of some
quantum system which
even in the you know the worst case we
have good theoretical reasons to think
we shouldn't be able to do this
i guess i would think of this as sort of
as really as an ansat so it's
a family of quantum states which can
be produced by quantum computers but
which we think probably can't be
produced by classical computers
and these may have some interesting
properties they may be a lot closer to
the sort of true ground state of the
physical system or they may enable us to
to really understand and study the
physical properties of these systems in
ways that we can't do with our classical
methods um so so i think this this is
something where
once we're able to produce these things
and run these algorithms on a quantum
computer we really are going to learn
lots of interesting things about quantum
physics
and so so given given that um that view
um um would you say that we have to wait
until we can do
uh actual simulations and well we have
quantum computers till we get
get uh to understand vqe or or do you
see a path towards
theoretically understanding weekly or
conceptually understanding it
while we are waiting for large enough
quantum computers
right well it's interesting that you
have this this divide between you know
running on a quantum computer and
theoretically and conceptually
understanding it because i guess i would
say there's a third way which is the
classical numerical simulations right
which
you can do on relatively large numbers
of qubits like
perhaps 30 qubits or something if you
want to run or maybe maybe a little less
and i think
this can give you a lot of insight into
scaling and
i think basically you need to be able to
run on a large enough size that you can
plot some points on a graph and see if
the scaling is looking
bad or or not bad but i think
the question of funding theoretical
understanding is also very important but
it's just
you know it's just really challenging
and i think this is why perhaps
algorithms like qaoa are a sort of nice
playground because maybe they're a bit
easier to
to analyze than uh that than let's say
vqe for the fermi helpers model or
something but
while still really being pretty
challenging as i think it's clear
looking at a lot of
the theoretical papers in this this area
so you can
maybe get a bit more of a handle on the
complexity i think there's also a bit of
a poor fit between these chemistry
problems and the usual tools of
theoretical computer science in the
sense that
in chemistry you care about particular
finite size objects let's say the femoco
you don't care about sort of asymptotic
analysis where n runs to infinity
so i think we as theoretical computer
scientists if we want to sort of
help elucidate theoretically these
problems we will really have to change
our mode of thinking
and and would you would you say that
letting epsilon 10 to zero would not be
sufficient to
use uh well because people in chemistry
are
interested in a particular finite uh
epsilon what they call
what is it called chemical accuracy or
something like that um right and then of
course you could let your epsilon get
much much smaller but people would just
shrug
yeah yeah i mean i think
the point about accuracy i mean i think
that is an interesting one i think i
think this is
a real challenge to understand
theoretically like the
the way the the speed with which the
accuracy of
um the vqe solutions say it converges to
the
you know the true solution as as the
size of the quantum circuit increases
and in fact i mean one thing i was
surprised about when we did numerical
experiments with vqe is how quick this
conversion
wasn't often the error goes down
exponentially with the number of layers
of your vqe
circuit for example which for me was
pretty surprising i was much more
pessimistic to start with
but it would be very nice to have a good
theoretical understanding of this
and i guess maybe just one other thing
i'd say is that
maybe the tools of theoretical computer
science are not you know
so directly suited to understanding
let's say the accuracy of solving
formoko or something but i think one way
in which these tools are very relevant
is understanding
the scaling of algorithms with the
system size right so
if you have a system that has you know n
atoms in it or something like this or
in electrons then it's very nice to be
able to understand how the complexity of
your quantum circuit
scales within and i think this is
something which people have been able to
do in many cases like designing
algorithms using fermionic swap networks
and things like this
where where in the end you can come up
with rigorous bounds which may not be
tight for particular physical systems of
interest but at least they enable you to
say
okay this is polytime and you know we
have some sort of evidence that the
algorithm is pretty efficient
right the n could be the number of
orbitals for instance
exactly right
um any questions from the audience
yeah i see i see some questions so there
is a raised hand by
nixon patel uh let me allow an extended
talk
nixon please ask a question if you if
you can see it
um okay i'm not sure if nixon
is hearing it about adam has a question
oh hi hi uh great talk reynolds
what do you think about the prospects
for a an exponential speed up
with these sdp algorithms i mean
um probably there's some way of encoding
shore's algorithm into it somehow if you
went the right way but i mean you know a
more
uh reasonable exponential speed up there
yeah so you can get exponential speed
ups if you assume a very strong model
where for instance there's some
some efficient way to prepare these gip
states in in a time that's let's say
uh polynomial in the number of qubits
rather than the dimension
so i think with sufficiently strong
assumptions it is possible to get
exponential speed ups there
um but then all the pieces been put
together like
you know we know that there are some
physical systems where you can prepare
gibson
efficiently but you know
seems like there's still more details to
work out right
yeah i i think fernando brandow has
thought about this i have not so
um i haven't even started working out
those details because i'm not
yeah i can't really find that very
reasonable sort of physical situation
where um
where all the pieces fit and there's no
polynomial dependence on n
m left but that's where you would look
though
i mean it would actually it would
actually be great to find any kind of
sort of
semi-reasonable exponential speed up for
an optimization problem and then this
this is definitely one of the
one of those sort of avenues that could
lead to one
so sorry aaron you started by saying
well
you could you could um you could um
encode uh uh shows factoring algorithm
in in an stp is that um is that
uh so i don't know for sure
yeah i wouldn't be surprised is what i'm
saying is
you know it's not wouldn't be surprising
because uh like
hhl is bqp complete um you can somehow
encode linear systems in a linear
program
something like that could lead to a bqp
hardness result for stp solving in some
sense
right it's not known but right that's it
wouldn't be surprising but ultimately
that's not really what we're looking for
thanks great
any other questions there's a question
in q a uh
uh can you comment on the utility
prospects of genetic algorithms for
optimization on current computers
uh i'm not sure if that's addressed to
me but let me say something about it so
genetic algorithms are
are very much heuristic
which means that um
i mean this this is also something where
um
i don't think much is known in terms of
provable speedups
there's also the issue that genetic
algorithms they tend to work in
iterations like each iteration is
another step of sort of recombining dna
or whatever it is that you're
recombining
i'm not aware of any kind of quantum
speed up for optimization problems where
you significantly reduce the number of
iterations
um so from the provable perspective
i don't know any good speed up for
genetic algorithms
yeah thanks or uh david uh
he has a question that's a question all
right so
sorry this is a bit off topic to the
to the things you're discussing so far
but i was very curious
the questions directed to ashley since
you mentioned that he's part of a
startup and i was wondering
especially given everything that people
said about how
far away and from practical applications
these some of these things are going to
be
who would fund a startup in quantum
computing with what kind of motivation
and with what
timeline in mind or the time horizon in
mind
right no it's a it's a good question so
i think
um i mean okay so the first question
about who would fund
you know such startup i mean if if you
look around the different quantum
startups that have been funded i mean
often the answer is venture capitalists
about venture capital firms or
large let's say institutional investors
um people sort of fed
fairly deep pockets in some cases um
sometimes governments
um and and i guess one question about
one answer about the timeline is
different people do have different
levels of optimism about this and
there will be some who say that we're
not going to see any interesting
applications in quantum computing for 20
years but others who say well you know
two to three years then we're going to
see some exciting applications so
um so investors will also you know make
their mind up and have different levels
of
of um optimism about the timeline and i
guess i would say as well that
quite a lot well perhaps a surprising
number
of um adventure investors do take a
fairly long term view i mean they have
funds which may have a sort of eight to
ten year lifetime
something like this and that they are
prepared to to wait for
some time to um you know to get the
money back to make a profit
and i think they do in general accept
that quantum computing is a sort of
long-term
bet and that they're they're prepared to
take this uh this sort of approach
and of course this is worth saying as
well they're um going beyond startups i
mean there are major companies such as
google ibm microsoft that are also
investing heavily in this area
including on the theory side and
algorithms and software development
and they can also afford to take a very
long term view because
they've got the cash to that matter
any other questions well i see a couple
more so
uh so there's one by eric on q a
in short does machine learning as a
whole seem like a reasonable application
of qaoa i wonder if you would like to
answer that
um machine learning as a whole
um well you know i'm not really sure
i mean it depends what you mean by qaoa
in a way qaoa
if you just view it as an alternation
of simple unitaries which depend on
parameters
if you have a very general view of that
um
you know you have it's supposed to you
know the unit one thing about the qaoa
is maybe the unitary should be chosen
according to the hardware in other words
instead of just saying the unitarians
are the exponential the cost function
and the rotations that we
originally proposed you might just say
let the unitaries be those that are
naturally given to you by your hardware
so that you you parameterize your
hardware
by whatever naturally wait natural way
you do it and then you run those
unitaries and try to find a solution
so if you generalize the qala to be
something like that
which is beyond what we originally
proposed certainly
then i'm sure machine learning could be
put in a context like that you have
you know but it would be presumably with
classical data i mean you could worry
about doing it with quantum data but
then you probably have the problem with
ronald's
quantum ram but um
i i i don't know i mean in machine
learning you
optimize parameters to get a result
um and i yeah i mean you can't like
if you want to call that qaoa i don't
think it is but
it's there's an idea that's similar to
that
great um yeah thanks uh so
you know we are maybe this is a good
time to
to move to gather town i posted the link
on
chat so anybody would like to continue
their discussion on gather town please
um
oh let's go down um so
um okay so you know with that let me
let me thank uh ronald for a fantastic
talk and to the panelists uh andrew
and eddie and ashley for a really great
discussion
actually since this is the last
colloquium for this semester
i i should also thank all the all the
speakers for this series and all the
panelists it's been
it's been really fun and you know it's
been
yeah it's been really informative and
very fun and
we'll try to continue again in the fall
and um
if anybody has suggestions about uh what
they'd like to hear about please let us
know
so so we're supposed to click on the
gather town link and then we'll go there
just help us yes yes if you click on the
gather town
uh link um then you can join us then
should we try it before you log us out i
mean
yes and in fact uh
um don't shut the gym
many of you already have the gather time
link uh it should have been emailed but
uh
but um it doesn't really work very well
on safari so
i always run gutter town on some other
browsers because
it's a disaster right chrome is
particularly
it it seems to work well on so
thanks by the way almost for organizing
this whole series uh i've attended every
one of the talks and they were always
very good
well great yeah thank you thank you and
thank all the speakers
and including yourself
thanks very much